villains they're calling us villains
that's absurd yeah we never thump our
chests we always donate to charity in
the right Rocko yeah you're fine I mean
your little clingy listen okay it's my
fault I've made some mistakes but I'm a
man and I take the blame and I just want
to say I'm sorry
Oh enough apologizing I think villains
kind of has a nice ring to it so you
want those to be bad guys yeah what are
you talking about you guys you see my
whole life I've been the golden boy the
baby-faced who could God after last year
I think maybe a little rebrandings in
order and frankly I don't mind this
whole villain thing yeah I mean we all
got this evil goatees already yes yes
stroke your goatees gentlemen because we
are evil now
ah the super team or the best players
here to crush your dreams I don't have
enough fingers for all these rings we're
gonna win ah a super team winning all
the games and destroying the league and
if you think that's a sin here's the
smallest violin let's go around the room
shall we
Kevin make me wanna burn your Jersey
surely I'd love to
well hello there I'm Kady you might know
me as the better MVP I swear I just came
here to grow by winning each game by
4000 play I play to waste a lock you
down on the Anna make some trays and
then all I'll forget what I learn me ah
super team all the best players here to
crush your dreams I don't have enough
fingers for all these rings are gonna
win ah yes we are super team well Chico
destroys the league and if that makes
you mad is some fire kicks for your dad
take it away
Ramon I'd like to formally apologize for
everything I've done though informally I
must admit it was a little fun but I'm
sorry to my fans for my teammates and my
owner oh crap I just snapped another
picture of my boner I'm David West don't
want a ring get that to me how dare you
take a ring from a Finals MVP I'm Sean
and my knees are back from the dead say
goodbye to the league will light your
hair we are supporting all of us place
it across your dreams on how little
fingers for all these rings we got away
in the SP I'm super Dean
if flopping on the floor like a drama
queen we don't just block we might see
it live on national TV every night
- sods ah here you wonder we didn't
Sora's ARS I bring you the heads of all
the other sports
oh my there's oz I love your attitude
but you might be taking the villain
thing a little too far there's still
some rules still loose as I easy all
right we're going to Game seven